Iago hated General Othello because Othello did not make him an officer in the army.
Desdemona, daughter of Senator Brabantio, ran off with Othello to be married.
They moved to Cyprus.
Iago planned to destroy their lives.
He caused Roderigo, who loved Desdemona, to fight a duel with Cassio.
Cassio's reputation was smeared and he blamed Othello for his misfortune.
Iago told Cassio to ask Desdemona to speak to Othello on his behalf.
Iago hoped to plant the seeds of jealousy in Othello's mind.
The plan worked and Othello suspected Cassio and Desdemona of having an affair.
Othello was enraged, but demanded proof of any affair.
Desdemona accidentally dropped a handkerchief on the floor, given to her by Othello.
Iago placed it in Cassio's room, hoping to prove their illicit relationship.
Iago and Roderigo both wanted to destroy Othello, but Iago murdered Roderigo.
When Othello heard of the handkerchief, he smothered his wife because of her unfaithfulness.
Desdemona's maidservant told Othello that Desdemona was never unfaithful.
As she explained Iago's plan, Iago stabbed and killed her.
Letters written by Roderigo further explained Iago's entire scheme.
Othello stabbed Iago but did not kill him, so that Iago would always live in pain.
Othello then killed himself.